oh look at smooth-ass skeleton Oh baby
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to potato
mode the show where we take your
favorite games and turn them into mush
we start by showing how good the game
looks and then we turn the graphics down
as low as the game will let us and then
we get real weird with it this week we
are back with more Mortal Kombat 11
that's right
aftermath man the new DLC for Mortal
Kombat including a whole new story mode
as well as a couple of fan favorites
like Fujin and Robocop which is kind of
a outlier here but you know it's really
nice to see Robocop in this game it is I
think for me I'm really glad to see
Shiva back because we need more forearm
characters in Mortal Kombat and this one
didn't have one yet yes agreed
absolutely also big fan at this stage
here the like retro stage that's like
showing the different the different old
stages for old Mortal Kombat games good
lord I do not know how to play Robocop
it's right this is you know we're here
just to enjoy and see what this
expansion has brought oh wait is he
gonna do it oh yes oh wow okay cool
I'll take it it's happening to me but
it's still cool yeah yeah well I mean
he's a wind engine oh that's my first
time seeing that and that is it's a heck
of a fatality well so I mean if you guys
wanted to see how the potatoe flying
normally works you can go check out our
last episode where we potato fide mortal
most of mortal kombat but now I think
we're gonna just get right into seeing
how this new content looks yeah get to
the good stuff
alright Robocop what you got what do you
got oh that's good I like I always got
multiple colors going on yeah it's
pretty good look like a like a water
watermelon John it's still gonna be food
we'll never be able to escape if it
I do not know whom I can trust
here you may start with me Alex Murphy
how do you know oh no you can't see
let's guess even more retro now you can
see individual lines of pixels alright I
can recognize the trees I know we are
whoo there we go there we go yeah that's
what we're looking for
oh yeah 209 shows up yeah that's sick
you've got some good cameos in there
that's really cool that is really cool
are the arrows supposed to be
see-through or is that no I think they
are I think they're supposed to be lucky
wind spirit arrows that makes sense
you want you want the fatality for this
well I spoke to now we'll go through all
the papers you in fact you know why
don't we just go do that right now okay
all right oh no okay his vision isn't
misstep oh yeah not like a terminators
buzz yeah superior technology man that's
pretty good I think you're bait three
out of ten because there's there's no
heat gets her brain go sure there's just
other stuff now damn that's a gnarly
finisher it is wait till you see the
next one though
[Applause]
whoa did it a shooter in the crotch you
bet he did yeah you can't have Robocop
not shoot someone in the crotch what do
you have him anywhere it's very very
important there's something about seeing
these fatalities for the very first time
in potato mode oh yeah that's gonna be a
real treat it's real real good there's
that that peanut buttery Center we see
it again the arms look likes stepping on
people that arm thing made me really
uncomfortable even in potato mode I was
prepared for it and I wasn't actually
prepared for it look I knew it was
coming
good lord Mortal Kombat y'all need help
oh I would know oh whoa
yes jaw pops off I know she's not done
yet badness disgusting I know I love it
the potato mow doesn't make it any less
yes well what was the title for the last
video we make them family
family-friendly this is a famine really
about this that was the complete lie
yeah this one's just gusher shish-kebab
oh no oh no you think that that's it but
it gets worse Oh you can't really see
the tornado so it looks like she's just
floating so what happened was Fujin made
a tornado out of wind and lifted them up
okay surround them yeah I was gonna say
I'm not really sure that's happening
yep that the impact and shear show of of
raw strength and ability that Fujin has
doesn't come through when potato mode I
guess okay let's move on to those the
stage fatalities yah yah yah hah stand
close hmm down down down beat oh my god
Jake are you ready are you ready for the
influent sure all right you did close
down down down B I'm noticing a pattern
here oh baby the gusher group down in
the green goop was mixing to make a nice
gradient that's really pretty that's
that's nice alright so you guys get
ready for some it's a little bit
different hmm no stant closes have you
press down down down beat ah [ __ ] mixing
it up yeah
oh you can see it arcade cabinets so
what did I miss on the screen there so
on the screen it played the finishing
thing and then on that screen that's
popped out of the arcade cabinet
it says fatality in the old font oh
that's cool so the last thing that
they've added to this game is
friendships everyone has one so let's go
ahead and pick a couple of really really
good ones actual food looks less edible
than most of the things that have come
out of Devore I'm just gonna say it uh
maybe we can it was not how to cook
those sausages or something I don't
trust Kane but when it comes to if he
was I would not accept anything he gave
me at a barbecue it's weird seeing him
without his mask on yeah I like those
ducks
those are good ducks so I was watching
the video and I'm like men it's really
weird to see Mortal Kombat characters
happy yeah the idea of them looking okay
I'm smiling he would never do that
oh absolutely not oh oh he's beard look
at that yeah right whatever pops tickle
though popsicle looks good it does this
is Devorah popsicle
Oh teddy bear it's not there's no face
it looks melted in kind of dangerous I
don't I wouldn't trust also I I think
when he pulled his his chain back the
chain actually shot backwards through
his arm off the screen but - but oh
maybe I also might lost my mind so we
can get like an instant replay on that
or something but it scared me oh okay it
actually kept the photos just gonna say
that was all actually kind of together
oh he should do Kings cuz it's a border
line yeah cos of a reference oh heck
yeah yeah oh right that's so good just
like my boy here you set set the way I
miss Yuki I miss you ma shumou where you
bet it boys
oh that's so good it really is I also
love the the friendships that just like
keep going and you can just watch looped
forever
yeah look at him he'll never mess up
damn damn noob go for it man Oh real
cool hold on we're onto something
okay how clearly look I lose my mind
that's pretty awesome
I want a Raiden skin that's just that
I'll be back
[Laughter]
it's just who is it the pitch meeting it
was like the terminator needs to do dumb
motorcycle tricks I don't know but
that's a real good one I love this like
look back he does right here yeah break
it down yeah you couldn't have given him
anything else really it's too good all
right what's it gonna look like
so the proud of you scarlet it's
beautiful I can ailed it honey
Oh like good ghost wolf boy
whoa look at the UH the eagle like its
wings were missing yeah well I love that
bear so much just to be either Oh dead
alright Ben we saved the best for last
we really did yeah there it is wait for
me oh it's hardly touched all that's
interesting it's glorious it's beautiful
you can't break it with the potato fire
as you should
oh beard though oh my god
all right everybody thank you for
watching this episode of potato mode if
you enjoyed it please give this video a
like hit subscribe if you already
haven't because that tells us that you
enjoy these potato modes and we want to
do more of them do you have any
recommendations for future potato modes
please let us know we got a couple of
good ideas but we always value your guys
input as well and until next time bye
[Music]